would you ever forgive a person who
kills a member of your family in
September of 2019 Dallas police officer
amber Geiger was sentenced for murder
and then the brother of the victim
forgave her
Brent John was 18 years old and I joined
the rest of the country watching on
television in awe at that act of grace
but I also worried I worried the people
who are African American like Bradshaw
are expected to forgive more often than
other people and I worried that a white
police officer like Amber Geiger
receives a lesser sentence than other
people who commit wrongful killings but
because I'm a law professor I also
worried about the law itself the law
leans so severely towards punishment
these days that it's part of the problem
and that's what I want to talk about
here the powerful example of one
individuals forgiveness makes me worry
that lawyers and officials too often
overlook the tools that law itself
creates to allow forgiveness when the
principle should be the cornerstone of a
thriving society I worry that lawyers
and officials do not adequately use the
tools of forgiveness by which I mean
letting go of justified grievance and
those tools are many they include
pardons commutations expungement
bankruptcy for debt and the discretion
that's held by police and prosecutors
and judges but I also worry I worry a
lot I worry that these tools when used
replicate the disparities the inequity
along the lines of race and class and
other markers of advantage and
disadvantage biases or privileged access
or at work when united states presidents
pardon people charged with crimes
historically white people pardoned four
times as often as members of minority
groups for the same crime same sentence
forgiveness between individuals is
supported by every religious tradition
every philosophic tradition and medical
evidence now shows the health benefits
of letting go of grievances and
resentments as Nelson Mandela led South
Africa's transition from apartheid to
democracy he explained resentment is
like drinking a poison and hoping it
will kill your enemies law can remove
the penalties for those who apologize
and seek forgiveness for example in 39
states in the united states and the
District of Columbia there are laws that
allow medical professionals to apologize
when something goes wrong and not fear
that that statement could later be used
against them in an action for damages
more actively bankruptcy law offers
debtors under some conditions the chance
to start anew
Pardons and expungements sealing
criminal records can - I have been
teaching law for almost 40 years hard to
believe but recently I realized that we
don't teach law students about the tools
of forgiveness that are within the legal
system and nor the legal law schools
usually explore the potential for new
avenues for forgiveness that law can
adopt or assist these are lost
opportunities these are lost obligations
even because the students that I teach
will become prosecutors judges governors
presidents
Barack Obama my former student used his
power as the president of the United
States to give pardons that released
several hundred people from prison after
the law changed to provide shorter
sentences for the same drug crimes for
which they had been convicted but if he
hadn't used his pardon power they would
still be in prison legal tools of
forgiveness should be used more but not
without reason and not with bias a New
Yorker cartoon shows a judge with a big
nose and a big moustache looking down at
the defendant with the exact same nose
an exact same mustache and says
obviously not guilty
forgiveness could undermine the
commitment that law has to treat people
the same under the same circumstances to
apply rules evenly in this age of
resentment mass incarceration widespread
consumer debt we need more forgiveness
but we need a philosophy of forgiveness
we need to forgive her fairly contrast
the treatment globally of child soldiers
with the treatment of juvenile offenders
in the United States International Human
Rights condemn and punish adults who
involve children in armed conflict as
those most responsible but treat the
children themselves quite differently
the International Criminal Court
now with 122 member nations convicted
Thomas Lubanga war load in or Lord in
the Congo for enlisting recruiting and
deploying children teens as soldiers
many nations commit to ensuring that
people under the age of 15 do not become
child soldiers and most nations treats
those who do become soldiers not as
objects of punishment but as people
deserving a fresh start
compare in contrast how the United
States treats juvenile offenders where
we severe
punished miners often moving them to
adult courts even adult prisons and yet
like child soldiers teens and children
are drawn into violent activity in the
United States when there are few options
when they're threatened or when adults
induce them with money or ideology the
rhetoric of innocence is resonant when
we talk about child soldiers but not
when we talk about teen gang members in
the United States yet in both settings
youth are caught in worlds that are made
by adults and forgiveness can offer both
accountability and fresh starts what if
instead young people caught in criminal
activity and violence could have chances
to accept responsibility while learning
and rebuilding their lives and their own
communities legal frameworks inviting
youth to describe their conduct could
also involve community members to hear
and forgive called restorative justice
such efforts emphasize accountability
and service rather than punishment many
schools in the United States have turned
to use restorative justice methods to
resolve conflicts and to prevent them
and to disrupt the school to Prison
Pipeline some American high schools have
replaced automatic suspensions with
opportunities for victims to narrate
their experiences and for offenders to
take responsibility for their actions as
they describe their experiences and
feelings about a theft or hateful
graffiti or a verbal or physical assault
the victims and offenders often express
strong emotions and other members of the
community take turns describing the
impact of the offense on them the leader
is often a student's peer who is trained
to de-escalate the conflict and
orchestrate a conversation about what
the offender can do that would help the
victim together they come to an
agreement about how to move forward what
they wronged or do
can do to repair the injury and what all
could do to better avoid future future
conflicts consider this example recently
in a publication young woman named
Mercedes M transferred in California
from one high school to another after
she was so repeatedly suspended in her
old high school for getting into fights
and here in her new high school two
other young women accused her of lying
and called her the B word a counselor
came over and talked to her and earned
enough trust that she acknowledged she
had stolen the shoes of one of the other
classmates turns out the three of them
had known each other for a long time and
they didn't know any other way to deal
with each other other than to fight the
facilitator invited them to participate
in a circle a confidential conversation
about what happened and they agreed and
initially each of them expressed a lot
of emotion and then Mercedes apologized
and she said she had stolen the shoes
but she did so because she wanted to
sell them and take the money to pay for
a drug test so that her mother could
show she was clean and tried to regain
custody of two younger children who were
then in state protective care the other
girls heard this saw Mercedes crying and
they hugged her they did not ask her to
return what she'd stolen but they did
say they wanted a restart they wanted a
reason they could trust her later
Mercedes explained that she was sure she
would have been a suspended if they
hadn't had this process and her high
school has reduced suspensions by more
than half to the use of this kind of
restorative justice method restorative
justice alternatives involve offenders
and victims in communicating in ways
that an adversarial and defensive
process does not allow and it's become
the go-to method in places like the
District of Columbia
juvenile justice system and innovations
like Los Angeles's Teen Court
if tuned to fairness forgiveness methods
like bankruptcy would be available not
only for the for-profit college that
goes belly-up but also for the students
stuck with the loans pardons would not
be given to campaign contributors and
black men would no longer have 20%
longer criminal sentences than two white
men due to how judges exercise
discretion forgiveness across the board
is one way to avoid such biases
sometimes a society just needs a reset
when it comes to punishment and debt the
Bible calls for periodic forgiveness of
debts and freeing prisoners and it
recently helped to inspire a global
movement Jubilee 2000 joined Pope John
Paul the second and Rockstar bono and
over 60 nations in an effort to seek the
cancellation and succeed in cancelling
the debt of developing countries
amounting to over 100 billion dollars of
debt cancelled resulting in measurable
reduction in poverty in a similar spirit
there are people who are copying the
techniques of commercial debt collectors
who purchase debt for pennies on the
dollar and then seek to enforce it late
night television host John Oliver
partnered with a non-profit group called
our IP medical debt and for only $60,000
they purchased 15 million dollars worth
of medical debt and then they forgave it
that allowed nearly 9,000 people to have
a restart in their lives this kind of
precedent should trigger and encourage
more such actions it's time for a reset
given mass incarceration medical and
consumer debt and given indigent
criminal defendants who are charged and
put in debt because they're expected to
pay for their own probation officers and
their own electronic monitors forgiving
violations of law or promises to pay
back loans does pose risks forgiveness
may encourage more violations economists
even have a name for it they call it
moral hazard
should there be amnesty for immigration
violations should a president offer
pardons to protect himself or to induce
law breaking these are tough questions
for our time but escalating resentments
hold their own dangers so does
attributing blame to individuals for
circumstances largely outside their own
control to ask how law may forgive is
not to deny the fact of wrongdoing
rather it's to widen the lens to enable
glimpses of the larger patterns and to
enable new choices that can go forward
if we can wipe the slate clean thank you
[Applause]
[Music]